[Music]
is it difficult for you you have parents
that are watching you and in a very
violent situations and sometimes very
sexual situations is that difficult if
you're for your family yeah I mean I'm
from South Carolina which is kind of a
conservative States and Trueblood is
definitely not a show for my grandmom
right by any means she has tried to
watch it I've been on it since season
two and she stopped watching when the
orgies happens and that's okay no I
don't blame her that's what my
grandmother started watching [ __ ] jeez
you gotta check this out
my grandmother's a gold prospectors
golden em huge uh so really so that was
that make it for an awkward conversation
with her she just not mention it she
just doesn't mention that anymore but my
parents on the other hand have seen me
do a lot of crazy things in my career
they've actually you know seen me naked
on stage before so they're used to stuff
you were nude on Broadway is that right
I was yeah yeah that like an accusation
I'm sorry all right
you were nude on Broadway sorry officer
here she is
police report yeah no um I'm you know
and I'm just curious how one prepares to
I'm dressed in the shower I'm dressed at
all time very I'm very ashamed of my
body no it's okay no I'm not but if you
saw me you'd understand
but you how does one even prepare to go
out in front of a Broadway audience
without clothes on well you know I
actually was never one to walk around
the gym naked or anything like that I'm
a modest person and when I auditioned I
was like oh God like I know I have to be
naked then I got the part and I should
have been very excited but I was like oh
dang now I have to take all my clothes
off there's no real way to prepare
yourself for that you just sort of go
out and do it and actually you know
there would be people in the third row
with binoculars what some nights you
know and you can't tell them not to
bring it in
we would actually like in moments it was
Daniel Radcliffe and I and I would you
know be about to take my bra off and all
of a sudden I would see little red
lights pop up from cameras that's you if
they're not allowed to do that I know
and they had like a couple bouncers in
the movie theater another movie did the
theater that would come and try to take
the cameras away
what kind of perv is taking out giant
binoculars thank you when you're a naked
you would think but we would think that
they would be embarrassed because it
definitely cause attention to their
perviness
you know I feel so guilty about that
yeah terrible eyesight remember me yeah
you